this is a battered and bruised rockies
ball club that comes in here they are
without nolan arenado for the
rest of the season he's got shoulder
trouble they had to
shut down john gray their big
right-hander also with a shoulder
problem no david dahl no scott oberg so
it's a little thin in the uh purple and
white for bud black's rockies right at
the knees with a fastball
three consecutive strikeouts for gallon
diamondbacks coming up
marshall has some open space with three
defenders on the right side and takes
advantage just punches it into left
center
a lead off single
[Applause]
escobar got him
and juardo escobar with a nice play and
a terrific scoop at first by christian
walker
eduardo cuts in front makes the diving
stop right up in the webbing of the
glove
almost lost the ball as he tried to get
the handle right there and a nice pick
at the other end
couple of good plays this ball is lying
toward right center field and it's
going to be cut off there by calhoun
and kemp will get the third on the long
single
by diaz first hit for the rockies
christian walker down walker down the
line can it stay fair
christian walker home run it's gone
diamondback strike first it's two
nothing
that's number seven for christian walker
diamondbacks
take the early lead almost halfway
through the ball game now
lead game one two nothing escobar popped
up his first time
here's a fly ball deep to right field
blackman backing up under the wall it's
off the glove
cole calhoun's going to come in and
score escobar headed for
third and he's in there three nothing
diamondbacks
blackman had a bait on it just couldn't
quite close the glove
[Applause]
and he follows up with a fastball
strikes out kemp looking
seven strikeouts for zach gallon who
holds a three-nothing lead
matt camp kemp earlier in the at-bat
took this low fastball for a called
strike and then struck out looking at
another fastball later and this is what
happened during our commercial break
and it started out as what appeared to
be a very civil conversation between jim
reynolds and matt kemp it got a little
heated and
jim reynolds ends up tossing matt kemp
who was walking away at the time
swinging a miss there's strikeout number
eight through four and a third for zach
gallon
and there is strikeout number nine
gallon has punched out three consecutive
rockies for the second time of the ball
game and he's matched a career high
and that's a base hit for tapia and he's
just
excuse me tapper that stays fair for
mcmahon
throws it away arte will get third
and walker's hung up now between first
and second he manages to get back to the
bag
what do they call it a snowball fight no
ball fight yep
there's snowballs flying around all over
the ballpark
so we wind up nobody out runners at
first and third
again field in now for peralta who has
walked and grounded out
this is still loaded peralta base hit
walker will score they'll stop cole
calhoun at third and it's four nothing
[Applause]
strike three and there's a new career
high make it ten
strikeouts for zach gallon through just
five and a third
and charlie lines this ball to right and
it'll fall in front of
calhoun fourth hit for the rockies
and that'll bring up fuentes
[Applause]
and this ball to right it'll dump in
front of calhoun
and charlie to second so the rockies a
little something going here
two on one out in the sixth one or one
on mcmahon
counts to first walker to second there's
one ahmed
turns it gallon gets over there
gets out of the sixth inning a zero back
on the board it's four nothing
diamondback
they're on their way to being 1-0
against antonio's today carson
lines it to center pallar
oh boy that's on the ground and in for a
hit
looks like kevin fellar might make the
diving catch
but second base umpire lance barrett ran
out there and signaled safe but black
wants to have a look
[Music]
as this is subject to review it's in the
outfield
with a naked eye it looked pretty clear
that that ball hit grass first and then
up into the glove of kevin pilar
took lance barrett a long time to make
the call he finally gave the safe sign
that the ball was down on the grass
before it went into the glove
and then here comes cole calhoun now
hoon bounces it to hampson coming home
they get one
fuentes can't handle it here comes
varsha who hustles in
and the diamondbacks have a five-nothing
lead or are they staying out at first i
think jim reynolds is going to call cole
calhoun out for being inside the
baseline
[Applause]
jelly peanut butter that's another hit
for tapia that's
reed knox tonight he just keeps getting
on he's amazing isn't it
escobar backs up at third long throw
ball game brighton comes in and shuts
the door
a four-nothing diamondbacks win in game
one of the double header
it's their second shutout this season
and their second in their last three
games after they blanked texas seven
nothing the other night